merci les effectivement nous imaginons
ces périodes de vacances peut-être de
vacances de demain ou après demain en
bourgogne et franche comté avec ses
projets de center parcs dans le jura et
en saône et loire à nous avons évoqué
pas mal l'économie à travers le
financement de ce projet l'économie
maintenant avec peut-être l'emploi
clément de la croix on ne va pas donner
à part tout à l'heure avant le journal
sur ce thème économique et de l'emploi
est ce qu'on peut attendre quelque chose
finalement de center parcs d'une
implantation de center parcs
après oui alors pour répondre à la
question de monsieur lire tout à l'heure
qui se pose la question de pourquoi les
agriculteurs donc était favorable à
l'implantation d'une multinationale
comme pierre et vacances sur leur
territoire il ya l'aspect emplois
effectivement vous venez de dire center
parcs serre s'est annoncée comme 270
équivalents temps plein par park donc
pour les deux fois deux cas de projets
donc à ses équivalents temps plein qui
seront créés purement sur le parc
s'ajoutent les emplois induits comme
comme pour l'agriculture une
exploitation agricole ces six emplois
induits par exploitation est bien là
pour le center parcs c'est pareil pour
le coup parce que les centres pas qu'ils
auront besoin de services de bien voilà
si on arrive à faire tourner par exemple
pour approvisionner le center parcs une
légumerie par exemple pour conditionner
des légumes frais on va permettre à des
gens de travailler dans cette légumerie
on va permettre à des maraîchers de
s'installer et c'est tout cette économie
qui va graviter autour qui va être
intéressante
ensuite il ya les fenêtres compétitif
par exemple pour proposer des produits
locaux si une volonté certes ça peut se
faire mais il faudra être compétitif par
rapport à ses des choses qui existent
déjà notamment sur la cantine municipale
de lons le saunier qui s'approvisionnent
en produits locaux
donc c'est des choses qui marchent et
qui demandent qu'à être développé
donc pourquoi pas saisir l'opportunité
du center parcs pour grimper ce genre de
choses sur un commentaire sur harry
leicester sur facebook qui nous dit les
employés se sentent au repas seront
traités comme des chiens à leur passage
chez nous il ya ces emplois induits en
dehors et les emplois les personnes qui
vont travailler pour le centre et vous
craignez qui est pas forcément de
retomber on nous annonce 300 emplois
pour le fonctionnement en par an
en partie des contrats à durée
indéterminée de 220 emplois à temps
plein dont à côté d'eux des temps plein
des temps partiels dont un grand nombre
quand nous a vanté qu'il répondrait aux
besoins des agriculteurs en difficulté
qui seront des emplois environ 3 de
ménage à environ 300 euros par semaine
donc ça je vais t'en prie ciel 300 euros
par mois bien d'en avoir passé neuf
heures par semaine il faut voir dans
quelle misère doit être le monde
agricole pour que on vante le fait que
des épouses d'agriculteurs qui sont
aujourd'hui dans difficultés vont enfin
pouvoir mettre la tête sous l'eau au
dehors de microsoft peut être un
complément de revenus pendant flamand
mais enfin moi je pense que des
syndicats agricoles le monde à l'école
devrait avoir beaucoup plus d'ambition
que ça et viser autre chose que d'aller
simplement faire le ménage
la fonte rapide et prend fait circuler
la parole moi j'ai jamais entendu la
présentation des emplois a su center
parcs comme étant la nation pour la
députée du coup à la fois pour les les
épouses d'agriculteurs non c'est quand
même on est sur deux zones notamment sur
le pense surtout à la zone bourgogne où
le on est dans une zone où mes collègues
politiques le savent mieux que moi le
taux de chômage est quand même autour
des 12 % je pense que même un emploi à
temps partiel pour quelqu'un qui au
chômage qui était victime d'un
licenciement économique d'une entreprise
ne serait-ce que financièrement mais
même socialement c'est quand même
quelque chose de bien est important et
je pense que vu la situation dans
laquelle se trouve le pays en termes
d'emploi et de chômage
il faut savoir faire feu de tout bois et
il ya un moment donné il faut savoir
aussi saisir les opportunités qui
s'offraient un challenge l'emploi c'est
sûr
la façon dont ce jeune agriculteur le
dis on a tous entendu dans les débats
des jeunes aussi utilisent on n'a pas
d'emploi dans ce pays
dans ces secteurs ruraux je crois quand
même que même si on n'attend pas les de
leur lectorat d'où j'ai reparlé de 300
emplois partiels et c est ce qu a des
bons et les mauvais emplois en france
est ce que avoir des emplois à temps
partiel pour faire de la cuisine c'est
un mauvais emploi et qu'est ce qui est
le bon emploi en face est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut se permettre dans
ce territoire dans d'autres territoires
de fer voilà comme ça de gommer d'un
trait un apport y compris pendant le
chantier géré les entreprises on entend
aujourd'hui bâtiment travaux publics 2
entraves au travail des centaines
d'emplois pendant le chantier et je
trouve que le débat a été enrichissant
c'est à dire qu'on va pouvoir
contraindre l'entreprise pourquoi pas à
comprendre qu'on peut aussi contrainte
cette entreprise sur ces appels d'offres
sur le suivi ensuite ce sont des milieux
où tous les ans qui vont être mis en
place pour l'entretien etc
finir rejeté tout ça comme ça sous une
forme un peu idéologique je trouve que
ce serait dommage et des bonnets vous
croyez pas ces emplois induits par je
pense qu'il ya des emplois qui seront
créés bien entendu il y aura surtout des
emplois qui seront créés effectivement
pour les grosses entreprises qui vont
qui vont construire ça c'est certain que
les grandes entreprises pour le
connecter nationale qui vont construire
ces établissements auront forcément tout
à ses intérêts à venir déverser leurs
tonnes de béton sur sur les forêts de
poligné ou durousset ça c'est certain
qu'elles vont y trouver leur compte
c'est cette opération est une opération
de promotion immobilière
on nous fait avaler cette cette affaire
en nous disant que ça va régler le
problème du chômage que ça va créer des
emplois
je voudrais dire que créer des emplois
alors moi je parle essentiellement pour
l'agriculture est enfin l'agriculture
on peut pas comparer l'approvisionnement
d'une cantine scolaire avec
l'approvisionnement de center parcs
centerparcs est une multinationale le
groupe qui est chargé de la restauration
à center parc c'est elior elior c'est la
société qui approvisionne les autoroutes
est ce que vous pensez vraiment que
elior va venir des marchés les
agriculteurs même s'il s'organisent pour
pouvoir
elior il va faire
com de com y fait pour le reste il va
aller voir monsieur bigard il va traiter
avec lui alors si les agriculteurs
pensent qu'il faut continuer à soutenir
monsieur bigard pour approvisionner pour
commercialiser la viande c'est bien mais
chez accueil paysan on ne fonctionne pas
comme ça et je voudrais quand même que
dans ce débat on puisse arriver à parler
d' alternative parce que là on est sur
un terrain politique
c'est à dire que en fait on est devant
des choix politiques
lord les aurais pas clément de la
période aborde cette question de l'autre
tourisme juste en france pour répondre
sur la la partie de l'approvisionnement
de son interpark effectivement le le
groupe qui est en charge de
l'approvisionnement à center parcs pour
la restauration c'est peut-être un grand
groupe
mais ce que c'est pas à nous aussi
agriculteurs et élus politiques de
savoir s'organiser ensemble se
structurer pour justement apporter une
réponse et dire à center parcs oui on
est d'accord que nous fassions un projet
sur notre territoire mais haas à telles
conditions est à cette condition là
voilà pour cette partie là mais je
voulais aussi revenir sur la partie des
emplois avec juste une remarque en une
minute qui me tient à coeur c'est que on
parle de création d'emplois d'emplois
précaires d'emploi de tout ce que vous
voulez de temps partiel etc
c'est quand même des emplois qui seront
attachés un territoire rural et qui
seront des emplois non délocalisables
ce que des emplois ancré dans une
société qui demain peut migrer à le bout
de la planète
ou alors des gens qui travaillent par
sur internet et qui peuvent habiter à
tel ou tel point de la france demain du
jour au lendemain comme il le souhaite
là c'est quand même des emplois qui sont
rattachés à un territoire est de plus un
territoire rural qui vont maintenir des
écoles de la vie et nous agriculteurs
qui sommes les plus attachés à notre
territoire rural parce qu'on va pas
aller exercer notre métier en ville on a
besoin demain deux voisins on n'a pas
besoin d'être tout seul sur notre
territoire on a besoin d'avoir des
voisins etc à partir et ses voisins à
des catégories socioprofessionnelles
différente de la nôtre pour justement
qu'il y ait un
brassage social au sein du territoire
rapidement fabien genêt est ce qu'on
peut négocier avec center parcs est ce
qu'on peut leur dire prenez des produits
de l'agriculteur est-ce que c'est dans
le cahier des charges est ce que vous
allez pouvoir leur apporter vos
doléances
oui le protocole d'accord qui a déjà été
signé en 2004 entre la région bourgogne
le département de la saône-et-loire et
pierre & vacances prévoir un certain
nombre d'engagements dans ce domaine et
le débat public a permis de faire
apparaître d'autres exigences et dans la
décision de pierre et vacances rendu en
février il y à la reprise noir sur blanc
de ses engagements en particulier sur le
travail avec les compagnies consulaires
sur par exemple les marchés de travaux
de cet investissement de 170 millions
d'euros qui va quand même année du
travail pour entre 250 et 500 personnes
pendant deux ans au moment de la
construction
donc effectivement il y à ses
engagements et je crois que dans les
phases qui vont qui vont suivre
il faut encore améliorer ses engagements
de pierre et vacances des engagements
pour que cela pour leurs exploits cc
motorisés pour que effectivement il
puisse y avoir des retombées sur notre
territoire mais je crois que tu l'a très
bien dit nous nous sommes attachés pour
quoi on s'engage les collectivités c'est
parce que nous sommes attachés à ce
qu'ils viennent de la vie de la vie sur
nos territoires et que l'ouest de la
saône et loire est effectivement des
prises démographique en des prix
économiques et donc il faut qu'on puisse
réinvestir ces territoires
c'est près de 12 % de personnes qui sont
au chômage dans le bassin d'emploi c'est
effectivement 250 équivalents temps
plein ou temps plein 300 emplois
on ne peut pas passer à côté d'une telle
proposition il nous reste peu ton va
terminer sur ce dossier-là cette verdure
ce tourisme vert que l'on vend cette
bourgogne vers tendance et quoi vraiment
il ya ce projet il ya quoi d'autre
qu'est-ce qu'on peut vendre pour faire
venir des touristes et des territoires
moi je dis banco à monsieur de la croix
je dis banco quand il dit qu'il faut que
les agriculteurs s'organisent pour
effectivement promouvoir leurs produits
pour les développer pour les vendre pour
etc
par contre ça alors lâché accueil qu'ils
ont on le fait que ça c'est à dire aider
les paysans à s'organiser en développant
l'accueil justement pour avoir un
complément de revenu en développant les
circuits directs dont vous avez dit
qu'ils étaient qu'ils avaient le vent en
poupe
je dis d'accord alors là on est
complètement d'accord on peut travailler
ensemble et on fait quoi parce qu'on
trouve en venir à vous tout seul sans
que vous ayez besoin d'aller les
chercher
vous parlez refusé au portel de
bourgogne à leur dire maintenant on veut
vendre en direct non on veut pas vous
non il ya d'autres projets par exemple
la chambre du haut folin dans le morvan
aider les choses pour attirer je lance
des choses apprises en live et yahoo si
on frôle si on prend par exemple
l'exemple d'un autre investissement qui
est aussi un investissement qui n'est
pas du fonctionnement je ne sais trop
quoi la voie verte
la département de seine et noir est
connu pour sa voix verte
c'est un investissement absolument
vertueux c'est à dire que moi je peux en
témoigner puisque j'habite à côté de la
voie verte et que j'envoie les retombées
absolument de seulement mâcon avait été
précurseur voie verte dans toute la
vallée
c'est un investissement qui a coûté très
cher certes continue de coûter cher mais
il faut savoir que l'investissement il
est remboursé en l'investissement de
base a été remboursée et rembourser en
une année de fonctionnement
il faut savoir que en termes d'image ça
donne une image de la bourgogne qui est
extrêmement vertueux vous pas
complètement pas imaginer que le jaune
center parcs vont prendre leur vélo est
allé ferrol sur l'eau marine par exemple
ne viennent pas pour sortir prendre un
vélo est allé faire du tourisme en
dehors ils viennent pour se reposer pour
buller à center parcs
donc on peut pas dire que ces gens là
vont venir faire ça non c'est un
investissement qui est très vertueux
puisque il lyrique tout le territoire et
pour le coup l'argent va directement
chez les paysans y transitent pas par je
ne sais quelle société
moi quand je fais goûter monde off
charolais c'est le régime
voilà ça c'est est ce qu'on peut vendre
par exemple aux parisiens ou au bassin
rhône alpes puisque ce sont les bassins
de population visée ce qu'on peut vendre
concrètement venait faire du vélo en
bourgogne peuvent faire ça m'apporte ou
non je suis bien sûr il peut faire ce
peu importe où il est il le faut et il
ne faut pas faire nous faire croire
qu'aujourd'hui il n'ya pas de tourisme
en bourgogne peut-être qu'il a la
spécificité
on ne vient pas passé un mois au bord de
la mer ça c'est disparaître en fermant
allons gérer séjour en bourgogne il
faudra vraiment vu ce jour
du monde constamment ses façades cela
fonctionne et de passage oui parce que
l'année et qui achètent des bons vins et
avec et alors que là on veut les attirer
les mettre dans un espace clos qui
serait le même que la normandie où la
salle
c'est un travail qui construit voilà la
parole aux élus qui vont faire quelque
chose pour le tourisme fabien voulait
d'abord raison que la gorge ne serait ce
qu'une seconde pour vous oui moi ce que
je voudrais dire c'est qu'avec avec mes
collègues nous restons à la fois très
volontaire sur ce dossier parce que nous
avons vraiment besoin
on l'a compris je crois pendant ce débat
d'améliorer encore les capacités
touristiques de notre département
mais nous serons très vigilants très
vrai très vigilant sur les engagements
de pierre et vacances pour
qu'effectivement en termes de retombées
économiques en terme d'emploi en termes
de précautions environnementales toutes
les précautions soient prises pour que
ce soit une belle réussite pour la
saône-et-loire
cet accord avec ses instruments tout à
fait je suis tout à fait d'accord on
n'est pas là pour opposer un type de
tourisme à notre on est là pour
valoriser des produits locaux pour créer
de l'emploi dans des territoires en
difficulté je pense qu'il faudra avoir
des garanties on les négocie
actuellement un père vacances dont la
responsabilité est de décider ou pas
l'avancée du dossier puisque des études
complémentaires montée à la demande et
on l'a compris réponse peut-être avant
l'été revoir cette émission c'est
possible sur internet
la semaine prochaine nous parlerons des
impôts autres sujets avec une conserve
de tous
à suivre la deuxième partie du 10 13
très beau week end sur france 3